when I step back away from all the white
noise the people wanted to comment
people are in - there are things
there was uh I guess a lot of stuff
going on internally you know with the
through organization and you know it
didn't didn't work out for me they're in
Tampa
so no it was quite quite theorem quite
the roller coaster Coney Island Brooklyn
it's a brisk day in October at MCU Park
home of the Brooklyn bolts of the fxfl
the roller coaster surrounding the
stadium symbolized the career of the
bolts quarterback Josh Freeman who
ironically avoided the spotlight this
fall by playing in one of the world's
brightest cities
going from being an NFL player to to
play in this basic free agent league
ever have sex if L know there was it was
kind of a took a private Freeman by NFL
salary standards played for pennies in
this North East based experimental
Football League but friends call me up
and I didn't really like what are you
doing don't I guess when it comes to
money need to play but I'd need to play
cuz it's in me you know it's a love
playing football Josh Freeman was a
pretty good quarterback in the NFL for a
few years and well you know after he
bombed out of the league it was kind of
surprising that he picked this
Developmental League other than say the
Canadian Football League's many
quarterbacks have cleaned out of the
league but you don't usually see them
show up in a place like this he's got
the courage that not many guys would
have to slide to this league and then
try to try to play himself back into the
NFL you don't see that very often
bald said coach Terry Shea a renowned
quarterback guru has worked with past
top NFL draft picks including Matthew
Stafford and Robert Griffin the third
she also worked with Freeman prior to
his rookie year in 2009 sometimes he
locks those knees up and his ball goes
high his release points got to become as
consistent as anyone's in the NFL
meaning he's got to be able to release
the ball white you know out in front of
his facemask
sometimes he releases it back here and
the ball sails so you know it's just a
you can't deny that he's got the stature
and he's got a pretty good football
acumen so he's got the brightness number
one he's got he's got that ability to
not necessarily get sacked
he's just shifty enough there's some
things that are out of my control
I'll be in shape I'll be ready to go and
the 15 gives me an opportunity I know I
can go and play a play to higher level
you know but it's it's um just matter of
a team even I mean that way too I would
take a chance on and I've seen some
quarterbacks come and go and I I would I
would somebody's got to come along and
say hey we can we can make this guy a
backup quarterback and then see how far
he can take it enter week 17 the
Indianapolis Colts are without a healthy
starting quarterback with a potential
playoff berth on the line first and
foremost it was ok who's available get
the lifts out and here's the guys we
watch the tape you get them in here get
him a physical you work them out I'll
assign them both you know and then get
them in the room one was here a little
bit longer you know Josh was here you
know before Ryan once they got the
concept you know what the concept was
and what it was called in the last
offense that they were they were in you
know they can they can put it together
in their mind they could
compartmentalize every time you play a
game or they were starting at 9 its own
it's a big deal and no I'm definitely
very excited
I'll come into this this game it's
opportunity and I'm really excited about
going on and representing this team in
his first NFL start in more than two
years
Freeman showed flashes of his past Pro
Bowl ability including a first quarter
57 yard touchdown pass it was a great
experience definitely a whirlwind you
know all around my goal was to go out
and play well enough to win you know go
out and play you know execute tried to
play turnover free going out and playing
and well enough to win playing within
within our system what we have to do is
going to be you know the best all-around
best for the team know best for me and I
can't really say during the game I was
thinking about anything other than
what my job was that particular play it
felt good getting the win
anytime you end the game victory
formation taking a knee you know that's
a great feeling